ليلى نستمع ونستمتع بروائع محمد الموجي
ليله وفاء وطرب خالد تالق فيها عدد من
الفنانين العرب في بوليفارد رياض سيتي
احياء لذكرى الملحن الراحل محمد الموجي
حرص على حضورها متذوقي الموسيقى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بهذا الشيء
فخور انه جميع المثقفين والفنانين
المصريين الموجودين معنا نكرم
احد الرموز الفنيه
بمدينه الريح انا انبسطت كثير لما شفت
الجمهور المصري يقف يعني ويصفق بحراره
لعباده ولزينه فهذه يعني تبرهم من الفن
السعودي والولاد ولدينا يعني نجوم قادرين
على اداء يعني اعظم الاغاني الموسيقيه
واروع الالحان كيف شفت جميله كالعاده
صراحه يعني دائما مدعون بنش معك وبالذاتنا
هذه المره طبعا هيئه الترفيه وزاره
الثقافه فصراحه يعني الحفله رائعه ما شاء
الله الحفله جدا رائعه التنظيم جدا مميز
الفايب المصري واضح جدا على المكان انا من
زمان احب كنت احضر المي فاروق لانها تختار
بعنايه لعبد الحليم حافظ
وكمان ام كلثوم فلما تجي تغني تغني يعني
من قلب قلبها
[موسيقى]
غنى الفنانون على مسرح ابو بكر سالم روائع
الموجي الذي يعد احد ابرز وجوه الفن
العربي وارتبطت الحانه بمجموعه من اشهر
الاعمال واكثرها نجاحا
[موسيقى]
في تنوع كبير قوي في الحان استاذ محمد
الموجي طبعا اتقدم منها جزء النهارده يعني
والفضل الحقيقه للافكار الرائعه اللي
حطاها هيئه ترفيه وشكل الاوكيسترا الكبير
والتوزيع الجديد الخطوط اللي اضافها يحيى
رموبي ابن الاستاذ محمد الموجي للالحان
اكيد عملت طعم مختلف واكيد ان ده يعني
توثيق محترم جدا لاعمال
فرحانه بالجمهور الرائع اللي هو بجد
بيستمتع بالكلمه وبالمزيكا وبالغنوه
وبالفنانين فرحانه ان انا وقفت على المسرح
النهارده في الرياض انا مش مصدقه يعني بجد
شيء رائع يعني في عظمه اكتر من كده ما فيش
حد زي محمد ما فيش حد عمل نقله في المزيكا
في المزيكا من
من المودرن اللايت للتقيل لله للوسط يعني
عمل كل الالوان الغنائيه كل الالحان
غنوا له
برايت كتير جدا من فنانين عظماء
[موسيقى]
ليله استثنائيه استمرت حتى ساعات الصباح
الاولى اشرف عليها فنيا الموسيقى يحيى
الموجي ابن الراحل محمد الموجي الذي تحتفل
رياض بابرز انتاجاته الفنيه وسط متابعه
عربيه واسعه
[تصفيق]
عارف ان الحب خطير جدا ما
[موسيقى]
لو اني اعرف ان البحر
عميق جدا ما ابحرت
لو اني
فخر خاتماتي
[موسيقى]
ما كنت
عبد المحسن الحربية الرياض
[موسيقى]
المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات